like here's the question where'd you
where did you see the anime community in
the anime fandom
in like in like the next few years it's
really hard to say because i mean
honestly same i think it'll be the same
thing to be the same
i think i think it'd be the same but
definitely we're gonna start to see
more as you put it weebs than actual
like anime fans right like because i
feel that the whole
i feel that the whole genre of anime
fans is kind of like i don't wanna say
it's
dying but it's slowly becoming
not as like in like spotlight like like
saying you're an anime fan is
sounding more and more like you're just
saying you're a gamer
it just means nothing because everyone's
like you know you know what i mean i
mean i remember
to i used to play online games like
league of legends and i would admit like
a weeb joke or whatever
yeah and then like people would be like
you're [ __ ] weep you're disgusting
but now it would be like one person in
the lobby who doesn't know the reference
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean i i genuinely
don't think that much will change
soon we're going to be start we're going
to be calling ourselves otaku girls
instead of gamer girls right
yeah i wonder do you ever think that
maybe like the degenerate side of anime
might hold it back from going
more mainstream no i feel like that
subculture is always going to be there
yeah because if anything it's grown yeah
because because right now
right now it's it's like people were
scared that
anime becoming mainstream would make
this degenerate side of the
degenerate side of anime like kind of
calm down a bit but if anything
just because there's so much more anime
being made nowadays
you don't really have to pick up who the
[ __ ] thinks that it would calm down the
degenerate side
i mean i've i've seen comments online i
think the general the general stigma is
that oh
my god
as someone on the degenerative side like
seeing all these like new faces come
into it these these
just so wholesome like just pure-hearted
people coming into being like what is
hint eye
and i'm just like let me show you
let me let me open your world yeah i i'm
like the joker in that game
i love seeing people suffer through this
just like realizing
realizing that the world that they're
living in is actually burning from the
inside right
he's like joe he just wants to see the
world
yeah i love seeing the world alrighty
then just be like let me teach you a
little thing about dojin codes okay yeah
no but i feel like it because the the
big change i've seen
is not in like not in the content of
anime that's being made but just the
sheer amount
of anime that's being made like this
season we have like 38 [ __ ] shows
there in the season
i just couldn't give a [ __ ] which which
is like if you try to keep up with
everything that's watching
three seasons of anime in one [ __ ]
week who who the [ __ ] doing this you
know what i mean because 20 years ago i
think i think i
remember this from a video i made i
think 20 years ago in like
early 2000s yeah uh each season we had
seven shows wow yeah
which is much more manageable yeah there
was a period like 10 to 20 years ago
where you could
you could legitimately follow everything
that was going on in the season and be
up be kept up with like the conversation
with what was coming out because there
wasn't that much to watch
and now it's just okay what kind of
anime fan are you do you like the
mainstream shonen stuff do you like you
know degenerate stuff
idle stuff whatever you're like a
mixture of everything like that you you
could
pick and choose whatever mood you're
you're in the middle there's an anime
for
every niche in every fetish now yeah and
the thing is like i feel like the
quality of anime
in general has gotten a little better
because everything like
i i feel like everything is everything's
just good
everything's just like because you got
to stand out now yeah yeah it's it's
like [ __ ] tv like tv is so good now
yeah
there's so many [ __ ] good tv shows
that like every week you're getting
recommended like a 9.5 out of 10 you're
like yeah
well [ __ ] i mean i i barely finished
house of cards and then look what
happened
but but like the problem with that is
it's like it's like
biggest first world problem in the world
when everything when everything is good
everything's too good every when
everything's good nothing stands out
anymore like
sometimes i watch a seasonal anime now
and it's like this is like the
this is like the biggest seven to eight
out of ten in the seasonal anime and i
just forget it
and i compare like these these like what
i would call now like average shows
and i compare it to some of like some of
like the kind of like the mid shows that
i would watch
back when i was getting into anime and
i'm like way better but for some reason
i like i remember watching it like a
show like
off the top of my head maybe something
like darker than black yeah which is
also
i [ __ ] enjoyed that show but it's
like i think back and i'm like
if that showed aired nowadays it would
just wouldn't stand out
at all yeah that's right yeah yeah
that's the thing though right it's like
you know normally in an out of 10 rating
five is the average yeah and it really
says something when
nowadays seven or eight is the average